un tribunal ruso ha condenado a 25 años
de cárcel a Vladimir cara morsa es una
de las condenas más duras que se
recuerdan en los últimos tiempos contra
un opositor político Vladimir calamurosa
ha sido una figura importante de la
oposición no solo por sus críticas al
régimen de Vladimir Putin y a la guerra
en Ucrania sino también porque fue uno
de los impulsores de las sanciones de
determinados países como Estados Unidos
Reino Unido o otras naciones de la Unión
Europea contra la élite rusa una especie
de castigo orquestado tras la vuelta de
Vladimir Putin al crimen en el año 2012
en respuesta a los continuos abusos y
violaciones de los Derechos Humanos la
demir karambursa ha escuchado tranquilo
El veredicto desde la urna de cristal en
la que comparecía ante el juez y ha
proclamado que a pesar de todo ru Sia
será libre Un conocido eslogan de la
oposición rusa que en los últimos meses
ha sido barrida de todos los ámbitos por
las nueves nuevas leyes del gobierno de
Vladimir puti